hablemos de la relación entre el ph y el
pecado en soluciones buffer o también
conocidas como soluciones amortiguadores
específicamente hablemos en términos de
la ecuación de henderson ya silva pero
antes de la ecuación que voy a suponer
que ya vieron antes pero si no tenemos
otros vídeos introductorios hagamos un
repaso rápido sobre las soluciones
buffer un buffer o solución
amortiguadora es una solución acuosa que
contiene un ácido débil que para
generalizar lo vamos a escribir como h
pero también está en equilibrio con la
base con jugada de ese ácido a menos
así como lo escribimos esta es la
reacción de disociación del ácido h a y
como se encuentra en equilibrio podemos
escribir una expresión llamada k
qué es la constante de equilibrio para
esta ecuación y tiene un nombre especial
porque corresponde a la disociación de
un ácido y miren que es igual a h3 o más
por a menos entre la concentración de h
y no tomamos en cuenta el agua porque al
ser un líquido puro suponemos que la
concentración siempre es igual a 1
ahora basándonos en esta expresión de
acá
podremos hacer otro video en donde
derivamos la ecuación de henderson ya
silva -que la ecuación de henderson
hazel va dice que el ph es igual al pk a
más el logaritmo de a menos entre h a
donde h
es nuestro ha sido débil y a menos es su
base conjugar y como pueden ver la
relación que hay de un nacido con su
base conjugada es que el ácido tiene una
h extra y podemos reordenar la ecuación
de henderson hazel back para obtener
distintos tipos de información por
ejemplo uno de los problemas que vemos
mucho es que para alguna solución buffer
tal vez nos pregunte o cuál es el ph y
eso significa que probablemente
conocemos el pecado y sabemos cuáles son
las concentraciones de a menos y de h a
pero otra cosa para la que podemos usar
la ecuación de henderson hasselbeck es
para conocer la relación entre a - y h
muchas veces solo queremos saber qué hay
en nuestra solución dependiendo de lo
que queramos por ejemplo si le queremos
agregar un poco de ácido o un poco de
base la ecuación de henderson hasselbeck
nos da una solución muy fácil entonces
vamos a reordenar esta ecuación para
despejar la relación que es lo que nos
interesa si pasamos el pk a
otro lado de la ecuación de este lado
nos queda logaritmo de a menos entre h
y no sé ustedes pero a mí los logaritmos
no me gustan así que voy a deshacerme
del hogar y aplicando el anti logaritmo
de base 10 en ambos lados así nos queda
10 elevado a ph menos pk
y esto es igual a a menos entre h
y esto que nos dice tal vez parece que
no nos dice mucho pero en realidad sí
porque nos dice cuál es la relación
entre la concentración de a menos y la
de h
y también nos dice que estas dos cosas
tienen relación con el ph y el pk
entonces si analizamos esto podemos
deducir algunas cosas podemos decir que
la relación del ph contra el pk
nos puede dar información sobre la
proporción de a menos entre h
pero también lo podemos relacionar
simplemente con el tamaño relativo de h
contra a menos entonces
analicemos todas las posibles opciones
para estos tres casos empecemos con la
más sencilla que es que el ph es igual
al pk y vamos a ver si el ph es igual al
pk estaríamos elevando 10 a la 0 y
cualquier cosa elevada a la potencia 0
a la 1 por lo tanto esta relación es
igual a 1 y si la concentración de a
menos entre la concentración de h
es igual a 1 eso significa que tienen la
misma concentración esto es muy útil
para que lo recuerden siempre que tengan
un buffer y el ph de su solución sea
igual al pk inmediatamente sabrán que la
concentración del ácido y de su base
conjugadas son las mismas y esto se
aplica mucho no solo cuando hablamos de
soluciones buffer sino también cuando
hacemos titulación es el punto en la
titulación donde h
es igual a menos se conoce como punto de
semi equivalencia punto
de semi equivalencia
si todavía no han visto nada sobre
titulaciones no se preocupen solo
ignoren lo que dije pero si ya lo han
visto sólo quería mencionarles que esta
es una relación muy importante y muy
útil para recordar y ya hablé mucho pero
existen otras dos posibilidades para el
ph y el pkk por ejemplo puede ser que el
ph sea mayor al pk
o también podría ser que el ph sea menor
que el pk ah entonces si el ph es mayor
que el pk a este término 10 elevado al
ph menos pk
será positivo y cuando elevamos 10 a un
número positivo cuando elevamos 10 a un
número positivo tendremos una relación
que es mayor a 1 entonces si nuestra
relación a menos entre h a es mayor a 1
eso significa que a menos el numerador
es mayor que el denominador
entonces si conocen el ph y saben que es
mayor que el pecado de la solución
buffer ácida entonces inmediatamente
sabrán que tendrán más base conjugada
que ácido y bueno en la última opción
donde el ph es menor que el pk
tendríamos 10 elevado a un número
negativo porque restamos un número mayor
a un número menor y eso significa que
nuestra relación a menos entre h
es menor a 1 entonces el denominador h a
es mayor que el numerador así que
podemos usar la ecuación de henderson
hash elba y simplemente analizar la
relación entre el pk
y el ph y dependiendo de si son iguales
o si uno es mayor que el otro podemos
saber inmediatamente
cuál es la relación entre el ácido y la
base conjugada es muy fácil de deducir y
miren lo hicimos en unos minutos no se
preocupen si no se acuerdan de esto
siempre yo generalmente me acuerdo de
que cuando él
es igual al pk tenemos la misma
concentración y después si ya no me
acuerdo
puedo deducir las otras relaciones